انا انا الصوره تتكلم ههه الصوره تتكلم
يعني في لوحات كثير قوي احنا شايفينها
سواء على السكوتر ده او على العربيه طبعا
قبل الرسم ده كله السكوتر ده كان فيه خدوش
كثير العربيه دي كان فيها تخبيطات كثير
جدا بس هي بسبب الرسم اللي رسمته دنيا هو
مش باين بل بالعكس بقت شكلها ملفت للنظر
وحلوه كمان جدا وجذابه صباح الخير يا دنيا
صباح النور صباح النور انا عايزه اعرف
المجهود اللي انت عملتيه ده اخذ قد ايه لا
بصراحه هي دي اخذت وقت مني مثلا ست ايام
او اربعه بالضبط
ايام دي اخذت ثلاث ساعات بالضبط يعني
[موسيقى]
الموضوع ما انا مش معايا قوي غير من مثلا
اولى اعدادي ثانيه اا لا ثانيه ثانوي يا
ربي ثانيه ثانوي ابتديت ايه ابتدي ارسم
شويه ابتديت احس ان انا بعرف ارسم يعني
لكن قبل كده كنت مش باعرف قوي يعني زي اي
طفله يعني لكن انا باحب الرسم قوي من وانا
صغير يعني دي موهبتي من عند ربنا الحمد
لله يعني اول عربيه بقى رسمت عليها وجاءت
لك منها الفكره كانت ايه قصته همم اول
عربيه همم كانت خدوش انا كنت باعالج بس
الخبطه اللي فيها هي كان فيها خدوش بسيطه
انا حبيت همم اديها منظر جمالي وفي نفس
الوقت تبقى شكلها حلو واا وتليه يعني ايه
تدي منظر اولا ثانيا بدل العيوب اللي فيها
همم سلا همم بيبقى شكلها حلو قوي فيها كذا
ميزه وبدل مثلا حد ممكن يرش العربيه انا
ممكن ارسم له عليها مثلا بتكلفه اقل كثير
من الرش وبرده شكلها يبقى مميز مختلف يعني
طيب مين بيختار الرسمه بقى انت ولا صاحب
العربيه وبتختاروها على اساس ايه همم
الرسمه اللي احنا بنختارها بتبقى مثلا لو
العميل عنده حاجه معينه مثلا عايزه فانا
اوريدي مثلا ممكن اعملها له لكن لو حاجه
احنا مثلا يعني بنتشاور مع بعض بابعث له
افكار هو بيبعت لي افكار بناءا كمان انا
ببص الستيل بتاعه يعني انا الاول باقول له
انت بتحب ايه اا بنحب مناظر ايه مثلا بتحب
شكل ايه بتحب لون ايه ثانيا انا باختار
حسب لون العربيه مثلا فبيفرق معي جدا
باختار حسب يعني الخبطه كمان او الخطيه
الموجود فانا لازم اختار حاجه تليق مع ال
مع الكلام ده كله عشان تطلع بشكل حلو لازم
حلو بس وفي النهايه بنستقر على قرانا
والعميل وباشتغل حسب العميل برده طيب
افرضي بقى انا رسمت على عربيتي وبعدين
حبيت ان انا اغير الرسمه او اشيلها خالص
هل اقدر اعمل ده ولا خلاص همم لا نقدر
نشيلها هي بتتشرب ماده معينه وفي نفس
الوقت مش بتاثر لي على صاج العربيه في اي
حاجه خالص بتتشال بكل سهوله لو انت حبيت
انك تشيليها وفي نفس الوقت ترجع زي ما هي
يعني ما فيش اي حاجه بتتاثر فيها خالص
والالوان طبعا انت برده اللي مختارها على
حسب لون العربيه وعلى حسب الرسمه لا
الالوان بنخترع حسب لون العربيه وحسب
الخدوش الموجود فيها بحيث ان انا اعمل
ديزاين يديني شكل حلو وفي نفس الوقت يعني
ما يكونش مثلا يبوظ شكل العربيه لا يبقى
مناسب لها اكثر دي اولا سنين اللون ثابت
مش بيطلع معايا خالص بغسيل او اللي هو
الميه عادي يعني بيبقى ثابت معايا فتره
طويله جدا وبالتالي خلاص احنا يعني بنعتمد
عليه بقى حب يشيله بيشيله بمن ده معينه مش
بياثر على العربيه في اي حاجه يعني اكيد
مش ادي له عربيته يعني شكرا جدا يا دنيا
بنرجع لكم ثاني يا سهام ونادين
شكرا لك يا ندى مراسله صباح العربيه ندى
حجازي تسلمي